Today was one of those days. So
we got some takeout today.
Guess what it is. It's Indian food.
We haven't had Indian food.
How long now? Ever since my dad was here
in January, maybe.
Yeah, it's been a while, babe.
It's been a while. I ordered this.
So lucky doesn't even know what's in here.
I need help. I don't even remember what I got for us.
Lucky never orders his own dishes.
I always order for him. I,
I do. When.
When was the last time you ordered your dish?
Most of the time, I don't care.
Yeah, you know what I like.
So you just. Yeah,
easily scan the menu for Lucky's food first,
and then tell him what's good,
what I think he'll like. And nine times out of 10,
that's the case. Ordered him,
I think chicken when? Vindaloo.
I hope that's how you say it.
What's his name? We've been.
Jason from London. Or Jake from London.
Sam from London. Sam from London.
We've been watching Love Island UK.
We. They just got out of the pods.
I'm invested. Lucky isn't. Really.
I also finished house of Dragons.
You finished it? Yes,
but guess what? I'm glad you didn't keep watching,
because the war didn't end up happening.
It cut off in Season 20. Season 3 comes out, like,
in two years.
It was all, like,
wasted my time. Yeah,
we got.
I love you.
Yellow rice, rice.
More rice. Rice.
Three rice. Three
says CS Chicken Samosas. Okay,
I get these every time from this place,
and they're never good. But I'm just hoping that one time
I'm gonna get them and they're actually good.
Okay,
they look pretty decent, but they're always so dry.
They come with this little sweet brown sauce and this,
um, green sauce.
Okay, what's this?
What's this? Oh,
I got this for you as a little surprise, friend.
Bless your soul. That looks pretty good.
That looks good. This is Lucky's.
She loves her lunch. I got chicken vindaloo,
and then chicken vindaloo.
I got lentil doll. I always get this one. What are we gonna do?
Little taste test.
Hmm. This is good today.
It's always a hit or miss with this Indian place.
I also got lucky spicy in mine. Medium.
Mine isn't spicy at all. You never know what you're gonna get.
Hmm. Is it good?
It's not spicy. I'm so sorry.
Okay, this is my plate,
and then this is Lucky's plate.
We also got two different breads.
Really? Remember what I got
to be honest, but I got this bread.
Also got some garlic naan.
These aren't chicken samosas.
They're lamb.
Second of all, they're still dry.
But I'm just gonna drown them in sauce.
But we're gonna eat like he is pacing.
Ready to get the show started.
This is what we got today.